cool
uh so once again thanks uh fdr and
organizers for
uh having us uh i
organized julia cohn a few months ago
and i know
how hard it is to organize online
conferences this year
particularly since none of us have any
experience organizing
conferences of this nature so
thanks a lot for your hard work i know
how difficult it is to
you know do things in these 20 20 times
um so uh today i want to talk to you
about
julia uh and in the next 30 minutes
i probably won't be able to convince you
to drop everything and
do julie 100 that's not feasible
but what i do intend is at least to give
you a sense of
why julia is interesting right so
i hope that at the end of this period
you will have enough of an interest to
go and
explore julia by yourself
and you know write some code maybe
translate some of your own models and
see how
it can help you and be a
good addition to your tool set
and if i can do that then that will be
time well spent
right so
the first sort of high
level advertisement of julia is that
julia solves the two language problem
that
is in some sense uh the reason why julia
was created
uh by its inventors right
so the idea being that historically
a lot of scientific computing
uses two different languages so you
write
the sort of core algorithms in c
or c plus plus or fortran and then you
write some kind of a wrapper
in python or r or sas or matlab right
and that's how most scientific computing
has been done for the last 50 years
pretty much
right so if you use numpy which i
suppose
most of you do you know numpy is
very easy to use it's uh it's simple
functions that
you know are very fast but all the
actual logic and numpy is written in c
right
and that works for a lot of what people
want to do
similarly r sas matlab have
similar models right and what julia
brings to the table is the idea that
you can write everything from your
core low level algorithms right up to
your
user facing high level models in a
single
language and that
allows you to be more productive to move
quicker
you know to write models and deploy
models
much faster than you would otherwise and
that's
in a nutshell is the promise of julia
and so the la
the next sort of 15 20 minutes of the
talk
i hope to show you how and why
julia does this right how does it
how does it say that it solves this two
language problem
so to begin with a few
logos you know just to show you that
julia is not
as much of a niche as maybe some of you
think
it's used widely both in industry
and in academia there are universities
doing courses in julia there are
researchers
writing their thesis in julia
and there are you know people in the
corporate world
deploying their solutions in julia
for a relatively young language and
also for a language that doesn't have
you know a big company behind it
we think julia has done pretty well
it's julia has been in the public domain
for
about eight years now it was released
publicly in 2012
and the founders have been working on
the language
for about 10 years now so in language
terms it is
pretty young you know python's a 30-year
language at this point
uh and so you know given how young it is
i think it's uh you know doing pretty
well for itself
right uh there are
plenty of books in julia now so learning
it is easy
there are books for beginner programmers
so you're not
learning julia as alpha as your first
language
right up to uh you know domain specific
books
uh that focus on using julia for
you know specific kinds of science so
for example linear algebra
or computer vision
and of course there are best-in-class
packages in many domains
so i think the basic idea that i want to
leave you with is that you know julia is
growing
it's not a niche anymore and
it is very likely that if you want to
learn
or move your work to julia you will find
lots of resources that
allow you to do that right
so having said that uh
you know by mostly by way of background
let's dive into
what makes julia special right why is
julia uh
language by itself why is it for example
not a way of compiling r or python right
why isn't it like uh you know
uh something like pie pie or uh you know
a different compilation mode for python
why is it not you know taking the r
language and using llvm to compile it
right so the reason why
you know julia is different is that
it follows a very unique paradigm of
programming called multiple dispatch
and what multiple dispatch does
is that at run time it specializes
functions based on
the types of the function arguments so
if you define a function called add
for example that takes two arguments
right so the plus or the add function
always takes two arguments
and multiple dispatch basically
allows us to specialize the
implementation of that function
based on either of those two arguments
so you know so plus as i said takes two
argument the first and the second
and multiple dispatch allows us to
special
specialize that function based on both
of those arguments right
and the specialization is done at
runtime
not at compile time and that's how it is
for example different from
sort of function overrides and java or c
plus plots right
in that the specialization happens at
runtime
so what's the big deal with that right
you know it sounds like an esoteric
uh compiler technology why would any of
you care
well on screen i have two examples uh
that show you the native code that is
generated
when you add two numbers in julia the
first one on the left
is adding two integers one and two and
the second one on the right
is adding two complex numbers uh 1 plus
2i
and 2 plus 4i right and julie allows us
to see the native code that is actually
running on the cpu and you will notice
that the native code that is generated
is different and not only is it
different it is
very specialized right
uh and so in the first case in the left
you see there is a
integer add operation so it says add
rdi and rsi which are two uh
you know integers on the cpu and the add
is the integer add operation on the cpu
right
so the compiler has figured out that we
are adding two integers and so it is
doing an
integer addition on the cpu
and you will notice that there is no
type check anywhere in the compiled code
right so all the type checks
to see if you know a is an integer and
if two is an integer
has been compiled out on the other hand
if you look on the right where we are
adding two
complex numbers right these two complex
numbers are composed of
two sets of integers each right so one
and two for a
and two and four for b and so if you
look at the native code again
you know you have two integer additions
there's
add rdi and rdx and add
rsi and rcx right and so again the
compiler has figured out that
you know a is a complex number that is
composed of two integers
b is a complex number that has that is
composed of two integers
and so on the cpu you can just do
two integer additions and that will
uh you know add these two complex
numbers and again
all the type checks have been compiled
out
and the code that runs in the in the cpu
is very fast and very specialized right
and the ability to do this at run time
is what uh you know makes julia special
this ability to um
this ability to
compile code at runtime to be very
specialized for the types of the input
that you are
passing in in your code is what makes
julia special
right and we will talk a little bit
later
about how this contrasts specifically to
some other languages right and
we will we will circle back to this idea
uh we will circle back to this idea
in a few minutes right now
having said that you know this idea of
specialization
how does it matter in sort of large uh
enlarged uh large code bases right
uh sorry for this sorry for my spelling
but uh moving on uh
there are a couple of ideas here one is
that uh
you know there is this idea called the
expression problem where
uh which says that if you have
a code base you can often
imagine a code base to be a set of
operations
that operate on a set of types so for
example your operations could be
addition multiplication
division right integer division
and your types could be integers floats
matrices dates right
and this is something particular in
mathematical programming where
you know mathematics is like that where
you have an addition
and addition can mean different things
for different things different can mean
different
things for different types so adding two
booleans
is very different from adding two dates
or adding two big integers
or adding to big floats right and this
is something that you
find very often in mathematical
programming where when you say adding
you say what am i adding right adding
two matrices is completely different
from adding two
floats and there is this idea called the
expression problem where
in functional languages it is very easy
to add new operations
right while in object oriented languages
it is much easier to add new data types
so if you have
adding on you know if you have
if your language defines adding integers
and floats
right then if you want to add matrices
then object oriented languages
make it easier to add new data types
but if you have integers and floats and
only addition defined
functional languages make it easier to
add multiplication and integer division
and you know subtraction much
easier on um
your existing data types right
but multiple dispatch makes it easier to
add both
right and this is one of the key reasons
why
julia is so great for
um scientific computing for mathematical
uh programming and some of this you know
you have to take my word for it because
in some sense you have to program it
yourself to really see the benefit
and i hope you do but i think this is
one of the
sort of big reasons why julia is
designed
in the way that it is and this is the
reason why
10 years ago it was felt that we needed
to develop a new language
rather than you know figure out a new
way of compiling
r or python right
and so you know again drilling down a
little bit what's the big deal right
why does it matter to you right and this
is one example of why it matters
so most of you have probably used one of
pytorch or tensorflow
and if you go to their github repos you
will see that
these repos are composed of about equal
amounts of c and python code
on the other hand flux which is uh
julia's deep learning framework
is composed hundred percent of julia
code right
there is no uh
c or c plus plus and yet
flux in most cases is
as fast as pi torch or tensorflow right
and you know it does that by being
100 julia and that includes
actually doing the uh auto
differentiation
doing gpu programming and all of that
can be done
using just pure julia code right
another reason why you know this matters
and sort of
drawing you know taking that same
argument
the ability to do multiple dispatch the
ability to do and
do everything in one
language makes it easy to interoperate
very large packages right so you're not
in this situation where you know you
have
numpy and saitan and scipy and you're
worrying about
you know whether a numpy array can be uh
you know sent to a scipy model right
or you know can you use uh
cython arrays and numpy algorithms right
so these are a couple of examples one is
a recent tweet that i saw
saying somebody solved a oscillator
using differential equations
and then solve the flow over that using
a
uh using a
using a a package called grid gap uh
that is you know somewhat similar to
pymc
it does uh sort of base in analysis
right
uh and you know these are two completely
separate packages very large packages
but you can interpret the two another
example is
a package in julia called neural pde
that
basically takes a differential equation
solver
that is written in julia and uses flux
which is our deep learning framework uh
and so
you know within a flux model you know
one of the nodes in the flux model is a
pde solver right
and that just works without having to do
any work
and so this ability to interoperate very
large pieces of software
is is one of the key
things that julia enables us to do
[Music]
another interesting place in julia where
a lot of work is happening is uh
auto differentiation you know any most
of you would have
uh you know would have worked in deep
learning frameworks and you know that
auto differentiation is a key element of
[Music]
key element of deep learning and we
think of
auto differentiation as a compiler
problem and you know the ability the
idea that
all of julia is written in julia a large
part of the compiler is also written in
julia
allows us to really innovate
in making really fast auto difference
tools
that can work with any julia function
right
so julia's auto differentiation works
across
any julia loop for example you know a
for loop or a while loop in julia
can be auto differentiated uh without
any trouble
and so that again is something powerful
that comes out of this whole multiple
dispatch
single language paradigm right
now of course lots of people come to
julia for
performance and there are you know if
you look in
search online there are tons of um
[Music]
tons of uh performance
analysis that shows you know julia is
faster than
some other thing and
and so i think you know it is now i hope
you won't i don't have to convince
many people that julia allows you to be
fast
but of course you know like all
statistics uh
you know there is
a lot hidden by statistics right so i
want to spend a little bit of time
digging down into this
idea behind performance right what is it
that we mean when we say that julia is
fast
right so this is
uh a set of simple
benchmarks around adding
numbers right so there's a simple group
as trivial as you get
that adds numbers uh we test this by
adding
i think about 10 million numbers uh an
array of 10 million floats
and and we add we add those 10 million
numbers
using many different languages and
paradigms right
so we see that you know if you look at
the results at the bottom half of my
screen
you see that there are sort of three uh
groups right so one is julia handwritten
and julia built in
python numpy and c with minus f fast
right
they are about seven seconds eight
seconds right that's
um a similar group and if you run it
yourself
you will get this grouping but you know
the ordering within that group might be
slightly different you know
but python might be uh
a tenth of a millisecond faster than
julia or vice versa
as it is in this case so all these
numbers are in milliseconds right
for adding 10 million numbers
and then there is julia handwritten and
c which is about 14 15 seconds
and then there is python built in and
python handwritten right
and so you will see that you know numpy
is
about as fast as it gets right and c
with minus f fast which actually does
simply
julia handwritten with cindy they are
all
sort of as fast as it gets and this is
what we mean when we say that
you know julia is almost as fast as c
and you will see that
numpy is also almost as fast as c right
so why would you want to use julia as
opposed to python number
well the reason in my mind is that
numpy is actually still written in c
right
and the add method in numpy right
the add function that adds arrays of
things
works only with a certain set of inputs
right there is one
version for integers i imagine and
there's one version for
floats and
maybe there are a few others for few
specialized types right
but the julia sum that you see in the
code above
is just a simple loop that works for
whatever
the type a is right it could be
integers or floats it could be rational
numbers
it could be complex numbers right and in
python
in numpy i'm not sure if it has support
for complex numbers
but i certainly think it doesn't have
support for rational numbers
but if you have a complex number if you
have an array of complex numbers you
typically in python would store them as
arrays of real numbers and arrays of
imaginary parts and you would then call
the sum function twice separately and
you know so if you have to loop
you have to again loop across two
different areas right
and so this ability to be to write
very high level code and yet be
fast is possible only in julia
and that's you know our opinion and
that's why
uh we uh right julia and we are fans of
julia
but that's the difference right so yes
numpy is fast
uh but uh you know number only works for
certain set of types because numpy is
written in c
and that's the same with r right if you
add us uh 10 million numbers in r you
will still get
you can still get very fast performance
but again that will be for limited
uh limited
uh types if you write you know
type agnostic code in python which is
you know a handwritten loop so
this pi sum a that i've written that
will work for
you know that is duct tight and that
will work for any type
of a but you will see that the
performance of that loop is
really really slow right so while number
is fast
you know a type agnostic duct type loop
in python
is very slow while in julia a duct type
loop
is still very fast right and that's the
key
benefit of julia okay so
uh that's about as far as uh
what i wanted to say about julia itself
i will just end
by you know quickly going through a few
examples
that people have used julia for there's
work going on and
you know building energy efficient
models again this
leverages our uh deep learning and
uh differential equation libraries
putting them together to model
energy efficiency so you know energy
efficient
heating systems or air conditioners
there is work
in predicting driving drug efficiency
efficacy
and that's again built on our
differential equation models
there is work going on optimizing
battery powered aircrafts
this uses differential equations some
chemistry models
that have been handwritten uh using
neural surrogates
uh that's some exciting work going on at
cmu
there are companies working on uh
gps free navigations for drones there
was a juliacon talk on this if you are
interested
celeste was a huge model to uh
analyze telescope images uh this
actually was the first dynamic language
that ran at petaflops on a supercomputer
right there is clema which is a new
climate model being built at berkeley
that again uses julia for
very large scale compute and then there
is personalized
medicine which people at pumas are doing
that you know analyzes medicine medicine
efficacy
for individual patients right
so that's really uh what i wanted to
talk about
there were a few questions i
think right there is a uh
thanks for the talk by the way it's
really cool
um thank you i'm at least convinced
enough to give it a go
on like a saturday or sunday that's
super boring
um so one of the questions we have is
like
the one you would most expect on a
python uh major conference
is that wouldn't be possible to
integrate julia code into python yes
and i would like to add on top of that
maybe you can give us also your view
uh from the strategy point of view how
you
proceed further future development with
respect to the ecosystem
that's there of course yes so we very
so julia has amazing c interrupt right
so you can call in to see
uh sos or dlls without writing a wrapper
or without even a dot h5
and we have built a python
interoperability on top of that
so there's a package called python which
makes it really easy to call
uh julia packages python packages from
julia
you can you know install conda from
julia install libraries and just call
you know sci-fi functions that works
really well
a lot of people use matplotlib which is
an amazing
uh charting tool and so you can call
matplotlib with julia data
and that does zero copying data
and so you know doing uh having a
multiple
languages in your environment is very
common and we fully support that
you can do the reverse you can call into
julia from python
so you can have a function defined in
python you can have a differential
equations
defined in python and you can use
julia's differential equation library to
actually solve it
right that works you can do callbacks
between julia and python
that works that works very well
uh there's a there's a site suppose a
follow-up from
tom saying um when would you not use
julia well
personally never you should always use
julia but
uh that of course is not practical in
most cases
and so you know we have built a huge
amount of interoperable interoperability
libraries
i personally maintain our java
interoperability library
that allows you to call java from julia
and vice versa
there is a library for r there are in
fact
packages on cram that use julia behind
so you know there's an r interface and
you can use our data
but it uses julia to actually solve a
jlam right
and so that works pretty well so
so so the answer is you know it depends
on your environment
you know if you have a julia uh pure
julia environment use p or julia
and if you have you know a mixed
environment
you can use a mixed set of libraries uh
and yes sorry you can call julia from
java
uh using java call you can do that as
well both ways
right cool and uh one last question you
can compile julia to a
native library takes a while but uh
you know it does work and i think that's
time so thank you i'll be underscored
thanks a lot thanks a lot avik and we
really appreciate you
giving this talk all the way from london